[Music]
we got some business to attend to a few
late minutes south of here oh you still
use south in spain oh
jesus jerry what the hell are you doing
here being excellent at tv sends for one
thing
also i'm done with shows pretending like
people have zero spatial awareness
even if you don't have the hyper
vigilance gene where you're always
checking your surroundings
one of your five senses is going to clue
you into the fact that someone's sitting
just outside your peripheral vision
and since we're talking jerry i'm gonna
go with smell you can park in a
handicapped spot morty anything with
less than eight limbs is considered
disabled here of course no one knows
where to park because they apparently
don't even mark the spaces
also not having some sort of hover
vehicle parking is just inefficient
planning there should be roof parking
with boxed areas for vertical takeoff
vehicles that don't need all the extra
space to drive around
the ferproc design committee sucks also
also
looks like you've got glizzcut over here
and then puisiza two doors down
and that's more poor strip mall planning
to have two pizza places that close to
each other
and honestly it might be three because i
could be convinced a place called dumpy
stump sells pizza as well
this works help me what the hell
i know right even though we know there
are multiple versions of all our
characters i'm counting at least 25
jerry's in here is the show suggesting
that a couple dozen ricks need to ditch
jerry's at the same
time when we know most ricks aren't
going to watch jerry around in the first
place
and yes i know the asteroid is cross
temporal which is just rick and morty's
for we wanted to make a joke here so
maybe this will make it okay you know
what those guys do in
in their fancy boardrooms they take
their balls and they dip them in cocaine
and wipe them all over each other rick
is a liar
eight balling is a myth and he should
know that those pictures of me were
clearly fakes
including a period in your hashtag also
when your vocation is life extermination
i'm guessing you're gonna just go ahead
and leave the geo tracker feature off of
the business card for exactly the
reasons the show later confirms
yeah sure i mean if you spend all day
shuffling words around you can make
anything sound bad my theory for when
i'm trying to force us in on a show that
probably isn't really a sin but
damn the joke would be so funny and meta
somehow makes it into this episode
here check this out this all full life
simulation game is exactly the kind of
thing that makes rick and morty such a
pleasure it treats the concept with
enough respect to give it all the time
it needs to be fully felt while at the
same time
not letting the joke get stale take your
sin off rick and roy parsons
i mean morty not a single member of this
entire crowd is cheering during this
spectacular play
also none of them have faces and most
are clearly copies of other people in
the stands
they literally control seed these four
in the front rolling control
veed them to the next row over i'd get
it if this were a cheaply animated tv
show but this is a high-tech game that
simulates an entire life
so convincingly that it becomes your
reality hey you sold a gun to a guy that
kills people
yelling this in a public place yeah
that's the difference between you and me
morty
i never go back to the carpet store all
right since rick is taking a turn now we
have to talk more about this game
because
how can he have awareness of both the
world around him and the living
simulation if it's fully encompassing
also is this game only for humans the
character is human and that helmet
wouldn't fit 90
of the other clients at this discount
dave and busters there's no way that
this would be profitable
and finally if the game simulates a 55
year
life how is it also showing the players
decisions in real time on the screen
wouldn't that mean it would take 55
actual years to play
who wants to come watch midnight run
with directors commentary on
martin brest has never recorded a
commentary for midnight run that's a sin
for the show getting its facts wrong
a sin for the collector's edition
blu-ray for not making it happen and a
sin for the universe getting me all
horned up for something that doesn't
even exist in my world don't engage him
press play if you can't finish the job
damn it
okay michael must either have
precognition or the ability to see
through solid objects
neither of which is mentioned or
explained so sin
how is this big guy unaware that a hole
was cut in the floor right beside him
and his co-worker was taken out
does peripheral vision not even exist
for these creatures with 72.4 percent of
their head being
eyes oh man what have i done
crashed into a heavily guarded fortress
that apparently didn't have a single bit
of exterior spacecraft deterrent
i guess portal transport that somehow
knows exactly where to bisect this
chesticle mantis threat for reasons
ex machina we can't get him out of here
he's gaseous he's not gonna make it
through a portal morty
oh sure now the portal has rules
open fire oh i see my mistake now i did
some fake research and apparently the
company that makes the portal gun is
literally titled
ex-machina inc it's like the whole
purpose of this gun apparently
fair enough i'll take back all the
portal sins we've ever done and by take
back i obviously mean double
also this room fills up with water even
though there's a giant hole in the wall
where morty drove the ship through a few
minutes ago
yeah yeah these guards apparently
attended the promethean nebula school of
just standing around and not shooting
your guns even though you're about to
die
or you know if you still have that gun k
michael dropped we could finish the job
and go home
you do understand i'm telepathic right
not sure why this matters since rick is
saying everything out loud and not with
his mind
it's how things should be it's how they
could be i could not agree
more this psychedelic unity musical
number that is like the doctor strange's
open your eye scene but less about the
astral projection and more about butts
goes on for some time we now interrupt
this masturbatory reference to a
different episode with some news
position
news position a tv crutch so useful even
rick and morty can't help but do it
sorry rick the reward on your head is
too high
higher than access to a creature that's
gold seems like he could have dished out
some raisin bran gotten a few bars out
of the deal and let rick and morty be on
their way
how are cogs that big fitting through
mouth holes that small gear troopers are
apparently this world's version of
stormtroopers
put these guys on a milk carton cause
they've been missing this whole time
i can't figure out where the main pot
starts and where the jerry pots begin
but if those three coins in front of our
jerry is all he has left then
he shouldn't fold even with ace high
these pot odds are way too good to not
play
and i don't expect jerry to know that
but i just can't let that kind of bad
poker go unsinned
i'm now way more curious about how gear
people sex works than i'm comfortable
with
i've been grinding my gears trying to
figure it out so to speak
i'm gonna find some fuel and take a big
fat morty that's my new word for
because of today's events explaining
your jokes which is hilarious because we
also do it which also makes it meta and
honestly the more we explain it the more
meta it gets
get it telepathic being that rube
goldberg the destruction of an entire
police force to escape somehow didn't
see this coming
interesting somehow didn't see this
coming it's also the title of my
why would all the ricks and mortys be
picking up their jerrys at the exact
same time
and so help me if it's just so we can
set up a hilarious taking home the wrong
jerry joke i'm gonna laugh my ass off
but also still add the sin
hey kids get a load of this
[Music]
they take their balls and they dip them
in cocaine i wanna dip
my balls
are you chrombopulus michael's target
very good
man the world can be one together
cause mouse without hatred
starts
[Music]
you know what those guys do in in their
fancy board rooms i take quaaludes 10 to
15 times a day for my
back pain adderall to stay focused xanax
to take the edge off pot to mellow me
alco came to wake me back up again
you do understand i'm telepathic right
pick a color
blue pick a number 17. all right i'll
call the two grand i'll gamble
don't splash the pot and in my club i
will splash
the pot whenever the [ __ ] i please